oh so smudgy and dirty your growth hello
you're on our way
Monday morning 8:06 a.m. it was supposed
to be other thing at 8:00 a.m. we're on
our way to take some photos with Robin
shoots on Instagram I'm for another
secret project that I can't tell you
guys I'm not yet but when it when it
happens it's gonna be I think really
good but it's been taking up a lot of my
time as it lately
so let's go this is currently happening
oh hello friary I am sweating like crazy
and so the hair conditioner is on full
blast which is why the sound is just
great quality we are on our way to
Chelsea Lately we are doing.we yeah I
think you're with me that's it during
the surgery
we're gonna go
you see I've done it twice already and
I'm doing it for a third time and I'm
really excited
yeah that was the end of that sentence
okay so we just finished at Chelsea and
the episode will be out by the time you
guys see this on Friday now we are going
to the YouTube space just should a very
special video with the one they only
John Green uh he's in town promoting the
float in their Snyder's I haven't even
seen it yet I know I'm gonna be a
goddamn mess but we are shooting a video
with him oh my god I'm here with John
Green and it's just gonna be a series of
expertise and they're gonna think that
uh yeah hi ray diary
oh yeah diarrhea oh oh yeah it's a [ __ ]
show
Roback Tigers Hey
hey now I'm in a car and I'm sweating
clamorous Township oh [ __ ]
it's hot hi guys welcome to Friday IRA
this cameras off for now but whoa I'm
making that you'll find out as of
yesterday look at all the fun friends
that was real bad I am sweating out of
both nerves and just general Heat
Sam Cooke your day is going well and
this is the end of friend Harry I'm
sweating I don't
happening right now yeah yeah yeah